[Music]
um
what can i do you for officer right do
you believe that this
motor vehicle is fit for highway use
oh i think that she's had some miles on
her
but she's still good for a few rides yet
i'm just having a laugh oh what's this
68. i can tell you're a man who
appreciates the classics
yeah well yes
yes well mr edward
oh uh be remiss not to ask
what is your purpose here in england
i have heard from afar the glories of
your night life
and i intend to paint the town red
well that does seem good enough for me
there you go be on your merry way just
uh you'll find
that here in london we are quite
welcoming
that's not a problem that'd be none of
my business for me to judge because
i'll tell you that would be very
inappropriate at me
uh unless there's anything else you can
be on your way
thank you officer youtube
[Music]
let him come
bring your honeymoon
and i will kill him
[Music]
and we're going live in five four three
that's the sound of the weekend i am
your host aaron the intern
i'm hosting now and producing with me as
always
in studio is sangai edward who is
a sound guy i fulfill my legal
obligation draw your own conclusions
are we good well good man how does it
feel to be sitting in the big chair
it feels pretty damn good got to be
honest it
it's still warm this is steven's ass
yeah well
how does your seat feel over there um
it's a small chair small small boy small
boy yeah
just be careful the aids that's right so
we are hosting tonight
and i just feel wrong doing this you
know
i feel like why i mean
why should you they're not here they
didn't invite us
that's true but at least we got hopper
we have the control hey buddy
a hopper hop hopper
oh ground bud no hopper no
sit sit hopper
no oh my god oh my god
[Music]
that's what i know
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's second annual
cultural appropriation month this week
we explore the majestic beautiful
and surly culture of ireland
[Music]
so uh there's actually a show live from
ireland glad to have you in
not video studio this time actually uh
live from a pub
in ireland in ennis ireland uh is jared
who is not gay follow him on twitter at
not gay jared
made s crowder with your questions
comments or your photoshops always at
photoshop
i fulfill my legal navigation structure
conclusions ireland ireland ireland
cultural appropriation month
because to learn about other cultures
and to appropriate it is to appreciate
irish cultures by the way uh for those
wondering not gear it is dressed as a
potato
free round for anyone who hits the
potato
this is we wanted to see how long it
would take for him to get his ass kicked
so uh that is an open invitation to
anyone at this pub in ireland listen
we don't know what'll happen here could
go well could go horribly uh we are here
actually for
can we we can say that now for uh one of
the santorum uh
daughter's weddings senator santorum we
did come out here we said well let's
broadcast the show because we don't take
days off work we don't do it
we don't do but
we went we visited ireland beautiful
countryside uh
beautiful topography obviously went to
in fact here's a quick shot of uh yeah
here's actually us going to the cliffs
what is it more more door just watch
i'll google it later there's a castle
where's that that's where koopa keeps
princess peach so there you go uh not
always as good as you expect them
to be it's not exactly google image
perfect i know
because i saw it now i have no desire to
see stonehenge
because i feel like i'll be disappointed
so listen we're in ireland and as you
know i've been concerned
about going to europe for a long time
we've had invitations anyone
um ireland was one of the few places
we've talked about that we said okay
it's pretty pretty safe ireland
obviously is not necessarily wasn't for
a long time a hotbed for any kind of
terrorism
we'll be talking with some of the locals
here about the recent uh events that
have occurred
and uh the radicalization that's
happening in in ireland there's kind of
a cultural shift there's a bit of a
political divide in ireland that's
that's interesting now that didn't
really
exist not too long ago no it's not even
just today i've seen articles coming out
saying
talking about the shift in uh islamic
immigration how they're trying to
radicalize people yeah you can't do this
go ahead
continue and uh just today on yahoo
page front page yahoo ireland
no it's just yahoo yahoo about ireland
yeah yeah
and you know they're probably cool
they'll probably have that picture
framed
that they were mentioned on yahoo here
somewhere somewhere in the near future
because
that's an event that's an event for them
yes good free let's try and build some
momentum with that so we'll be talking
about some locals here at the pub listen
uh a lot of people now know that one of
the uh the uh the
well the london uh terrace was radical i
spent a lot of time in ireland in dublin
in dublin it's been a lot of time in
dublin and uh there have been some real
cultural changes and there are some
people here at the pub who right away
came up came
up and where where we were from and
wanted to blame the atrocities
of donald trump on us as well as the
vietnam war
uh they just you know something like
perceptions of americans that aren't
necessarily accurate i think maybe we
have some perceptions of some people
from ireland that aren't accurate people
from the uk
so be interesting to kind of get down to
it and see what it is that they believe
and see what it is that most people here
think about um you know freedom of
speech
and sort of political correctness run
amok there was an interesting poll
actually recently in ireland
65 of irish people when asked said they
don't think any speech should be
banned even if it's offensive and what's
crazy is they do have protected free
speech in their constitution
but there are anti-blasphemy laws no we
talked about that with um i can't
remember her name but renee
graham australia i'll show you a lot of
countries seem to have it seems to be
kind of a trend of
free speech except this is this yeah
except this is a little subtext which
it's either absolute or really it's of
no value so all right let's bring in
some locals from ireland so we have no
idea how this will go hey this what
about the lady
you want to come on over you you've come
on you've been you've been a lively one
come on everyone here wants you to come
on at the show everyone wants it
just come on sit down and we'll we'll
chat with you
yeah yes yes come on over we have the
lady from we have home home
if you saw home alone too she finally
let the birds go she finally let the
pigeon go so let's bring her in let's
bring her okay there we go
all right round of applause for what's
your name well you need to get here you
need to get here we can't see it yeah
you got it
oh hold on i won't bite come on come in
closer i gotta bring in a little closer
there we go
okay did i miss the name did you what
was the name
molly maloney molly
she's putting on the mutton shops there
you go you know what
not bad you could give bruce jenner a
run for his money ah let's talk about it
now
well i saw you smoking the e-cigarettes
so um is that that's allowed in the bars
here
who might smoke another cigarette but
will it be an e-cigarette
no okay let's ask molly maloney
maloney now see oh geez these stools are
small how small are you people in
ireland your ass is so big
you have no idea how deep that goes
she's so perceptible she's unbelievably
receptive
uh let's no more let's cut her off after
the next guinness
what so we keep what are your
perceptions actually of americans when
you think of people from the united
states of america what do you think of
how do you think
of of of americans after meeting you no
no before meeting me
well before meeting you it was lovely
okay i knew this is exactly what was
coming but
when people in ireland when they think
of americans what do they do they
generally think of friendly people do
they think of brash people they think of
loud people i suppose
i lived in america a couple of years ago
you lived in america
yeah okay where abouts uh new jersey
you sound like you're making this up as
you go along um
new jersey come back here no i i didn't
i lived in new jersey
i cycled all around um
missouri which is i'm sorry i love you
all the states new jersey and missouri
it's like
i'm going to end up in hackensack and st
louis did you visit detroit
no i don't drive okay so you were there
for a couple years
i did and then i went to san francisco
okay
oh that was fantastic really you liked
it oh i
loved it i lived in innocent my life
when i was as gay as a christmas tree
went to san francisco freedom freedom
so i mean when you okay because gay
stateside so do you mean gay
honor how are we saying gay because san
francisco comes with a connotation
happy homosexual all of the above
yeah okay there's so san francisco would
make sense
well you know bill burr says boston very
irish boston is just kind of like a
racist san francisco
bastion fast how you pronounce it not
boston bastion
fast no i i was speaking english so
we'll uh with a mid with americans what
was it so you went there what did you
expect when you went out to the united
states and what did uh
what did you encounter i encountered
just such a good time you know they were
they're lovely
you're lovely oh thank you stuff you're
all lovely
you're lovely to aside from the fat ass
comment but i'll well
you know i have a fat ass if the giant
underwear fits
here can i tell you come here can i tell
you it's all
kind of rain now though is it okay so
what's the political perception of
america now or the cultural perception
abroad
well i don't think it'd be very good in
europe
you mean someone like someone like a
donald trump
or donald duck or donald duck yeah well
you know that's head upside down he's
the same character
we have brexit in the uk there are a lot
of parallels there right so it's not
like this is completely
uh foreign to to europe and donald trump
a lot of people would say it's kind of a
symptom of that
how do you view that i'm sorry i'll take
these that's okay you can keep them on
it doesn't it doesn't i i'm irish
actually so
you know brexit and whatever in england
we've always had this little thing going
on with us
yeah uh we've tried to repair it a bit
yeah now we have a bit of ice is going
on
what i was going to say devices
no no i'm dead serious our borders may
be locked tighter now because
of situations that have happened as
regards
london and and one of the
one of the terrorists being found that
had an address in
in red mines in dublin this is really
serious
for us as brexit comes about well here's
one thing ireland is one of the few
places that didn't take a lot of
refugees refused more than they let in
and there's been a lot more
radicalization a lot of people don't
know this in ireland with younger
muslims
um you've been here have you walked
around this small town
yeah we've been walking around quite a
bit yeah so you see how many
multi-denominations are in the town
yeah so would you would you support them
now being stricter
and a little tighter on security or do
you think that's
do you think that's a sad kind of
outcome we're irish it's very hard to
pin us down
i i think on that yeah it's very hard to
pin us down on that because
we we've been everywhere we we've done
this we've done that
we went as we've been everywhere yeah
but for the safety of everybody's
future i think we need to be a little
bit more careful
you think you need a little stricter
maybe a little more choosy no i said
careful well careful but careful means
stricter as far as i mean listen let's
be honest you have to you have to
examine you have to root things out
and it's strict enough right you know so
let me ask you this can you see because
a lot of people talk about at stateside
you know sort of
donald trump in the wall this idea but
because we've had this issue in the
united states and we
effectively have open borders where
there's no way to monitor people who are
coming in
do you think understanding now
experiencing this in ireland maybe the
irish people might have more sympathy
for americans saying you know what we
need to
we need to put a lockdown on this and
know who's coming in and going out
i think that america has so many
different
ethnic minorities in it that have
settled
have added to everything that is
including the irish
including the irish but i i'm talking
about everybody
they've all done something we all need
to find out who are the people
that are doing nothing right yeah we
need
people need to keep things safe
yeah and so that for america or ireland
in ireland with
all these bombs and all this [ __ ] going
off everywhere
we've lived here now
other people are seeing this and and
that's not right
right it isn't right it's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah oh good well i'm i'm i'm interested
to hear that it seems like you're not on
the street
why can't you i go to manchester
tomorrow yeah
okay now i'm going into a city that is
suffering with everything that is just
put up with
right and somebody asked me do you want
to go into the city center i said sure i
do
and i'll be wearing an irish color when
i go in there to say
i'm supporting manchester yeah
absolutely
absolutely but how do they get around
this mechanical cross now
how they get around this i don't know i
know it says but the world needs to be a
better and safer place but we
have all these things social media
all these things do you think they're
helping the world
even though i'm on your microphone
social media well you know i think it's
a double-edged sword yeah i think it's
double-edged shorts
i think it allows people like catch 22
situations
because this conversation can reach more
people that will be seen in traditional
news or media
and it can be organic and unedited and
raw and then on a flip side you know
people can be more disconnected than
ever and just just lie and then it
catches on like
wildfire or radicalized terrorists um i
mean your
your friend is dressed up as a potato i
know isn't it i mean
you know no one can no one can tell us
he can't
mr spud can you see mr spot everybody
well like we said there's still still a
free round forever he's a spot from the
famine
he looks like a sad um what you call
them
things here homosexuals not not the word
you're before right
no good god no no well many
many use that he's he looks like a sad
pumpkin
it looks like a sad pumpkin in other
words a potato it's june
yes so he must be yeah potatoes are
frowned
well thank you so much yeah we have we
do have we have some other people going
to bring on as well but i appreciate you
giving us uh giving us your point of
view crowds are very routing
yeah i know well you've got a scotsman
and you got a welshman right there
they're already fighting yeah i know
come here
there's glass rugby match in the morning
get up everybody happy eight in the
morning get cracking all right thanks so
much we appreciate it can i keep your
pipes you can't that's an actual
peterson authentic irish pipe and it's
expensive
you mean the meerschaum no no that's not
a merchant but that's peterson they're
made in dublin
you can keep the mutton shops you can
keep the mutton shops no you can keep
them thank you
thank you oh you're so huge darling bye
everyone
here in the irish pub uh getting
opinions learning a lot it's interesting
is your house on fire i don't know is
your house on fire
all right so now we're bringing someone
younger what is your name sir stephen
stephen
all right steven nice to meet you um so
this was interesting this is you know
that when we picture people from ireland
that's not far off yeah well this is
more
this is claire so it's sunny a town yeah
so
we're from limerick which is one of the
cities of ireland yeah there'd be dublin
galway
cork and limerick so it's a bit
different what she was just talking
about she said should have gone hillary
i find it interesting should have gone
hillary but she just said yeah we need
we need to make ourselves safer we need
to know what's going on we don't know
who's coming in and out
seems like that i don't know if it's
because the left right shift hasn't
occurred here in ireland
but there's a there's a disconnect
between what people want which is
freedom of speech if you look at the
polls actually ireland is a more free
market economy than the united states in
a lot of ways
and uh now people are saying well we
need to crack down on radicalism but
then saying
you know hillary yeah i think i think
that's all due to the media here in
particular because
i you won't hear any right wing sort of
media here so everything like rte if
you're on the radio so rte today fm
spin south west everything that they
report on is all
there's no mention of trump in a
positive sense in any way even if he did
something right
yeah so everyone here
unless you look it up yourself would be
on oh you should have voted hillary
because trump's a sexist trump's a
racist
uh he doesn't like muslims he doesn't
like mexicans he doesn't like women
and they'll take it all because they see
it on facebook or they'll hear it on rt
or they'll hear it or wherever and
they'll just take it as fact because
that's nobody really do you think
there's i know you're here with your
friends and you're kind of more right
leaning we were talking do you think
there's
um almost a disconnect where
generationally younger people are
are starting to lean more that way
because they've been raised in such sort
of a bastion of liberalism
because from argent we're a little you
know a little older when we were raised
it was just like jorah of george bush so
everyone went super liberal now
generation z
is kind of going the other way do you
feel in ireland that you guys are kind
of growing or are you just
outliers in a whole bunch of colleges
filled with leftists
i don't know i mean my parents probably
older than a lot of people's parents my
parents mean their 60s so and they would
have been very christian
very conservative and i think most
people's parents here maybe not a lot of
them would be liberal
i think most people even i've talked to
people in college i'd be speaking to
about this kind of stuff
a lot of people don't care so it's not
really mainstream yet but
if you ask them they would lean left
either way they won't
they'll just take it on board if donald
trump is bad what do you think they'd
lean left like for example if you ask
them about okay do you support freedom
of speech here or what do you think
about you know obviously the recent
terrorists being
spending a lot of time in in uh in
ireland
with you know these mosques going on
people being more radical do you think
they would actually answer left on those
questions because we just saw there even
someone who's vote hillary was
far more right on a lot of individual
questions and i i've experienced that a
lot
in my time here in europe i think the
majority of people if you ask them here
would say that and it's because they're
getting from the media that
uh the attacks have not to do with
the religion they'll say that like so
they even though they'll say that we
need
free speech say whatever you want but
it's all to a point so it's free speech
say whatever you want
for example i'd be on twitter and
even just yesterday it was hashtag it
was trending it was hashtag feminists
are everywhere
so and everyone i spoke to was irish so
i said
you know i just asked questions like why
it can be one reason why we need
feminism in this country and
the hostility i was making it was crazy
like
do they say you have a fat ass and make
fun of you sitting honestly they didn't
say that but they were calling me uh
john
before i even said anything about women
whatsoever it was just yeah
you know you're a misogynist like i
think that's kind of just the way it
picked up
it's picked up in ireland it's the same
this it's free speech to a point and
that's your game over there right that's
my girl
that's right over there is he is sexist
to see a misogynist no
i mean i have four sisters i have six
nieces and my girlfriends
he doesn't slap you around there's no
fifty shades of gray against your will
no okay
so it's just that's the way it's viewed
upon in ireland where
a lot of people who speak to probably
don't care what they would take because
it's
that's the way it is in the media they
would take feminism uh islamophobia as
fact all these things is fact
yeah without even looking it up because
that's what's talked about rt2 of fame
it's just
if they report on these attacks like the
manchester attack there's no mention
they won't tell you that it was a
religion they'll just say that it was an
incident that happened in manchester
they would they leave out the fact that
or london that happened on saturday
they cleverly edited all the stories and
the interviews of people where they
don't mention the fact that the boys
were saying
this is for allah or you know there's
none of that or allah
do you think how much that do you think
has to do with you know you're talking
about this there's a blasphemy law here
in ireland that was put into effect do
you think most people even know about
that that you can actually
be arrested you can be charged for
blaspheming and of course
you know anything if you claim if you
say well let people understand this
if you say i don't believe muhammad is a
man who he claims he was which is the
messenger messenger of god
is to blaspheme against islam so it
comes down to
who is the judge of what is blaspheming
or hate speech whatever it is
how many people do you think are even
aware of that in ireland i wasn't aware
of until the stephen fry
did you hear that that was where it came
up where stephen fry criticized god it
was an irish interview
yeah and that's where it all came up and
he got off in the end well i wasn't
aware of it i don't know how many people
were i assumed people
he's far left yeah well i wouldn't say
he's far
left he's again he's kind of culturally
left and i think standing up sort of
with the freedom of speech i think it's
forced him to become
yeah i guess he's some of that he's
pretty far left yeah
but i think in this country they're
trying to get rid of all
they want to get away from the
catholicism and the christianity i think
they want to separate that totally where
they take away
they don't want to protect that anymore
i don't think so from from things i've
seen where they want to take away from
the whole christianity and the
separation of church and the state
but if you're in school like they won't
you just you'll be like christianity
beyond the chapman black
all the time where there's nothing wrong
with that but you know any mental image
of
injury though because abortion is
completely illegal in ireland it's the
only place where that's the case
and that's because they recognize the
individual rights of personhood you know
to the unborn
um where do you see that going because
that's obviously deeply rooted in the
catholic you know
faith in the history here in ireland
well like that's another thing i'd be on
board with like
i'd be pro-life i'd be totally against
abortion i mean my father goes around
and need canvasses for
save the eighth so he goes around the
houses and he actually talks to people
and uh they would say you know some
people tend to just go away like yeah
so but they had a thing and it was march
the eighth it was international women's
day
in our uh everywhere but in ireland they
did a thing where they strike for repeal
so they topless they go topless no i
don't think so
they have they have put their [ __ ] hats
on like we had in the states yes thank
god disappointing
they they took the day off work
just took the day off work most of them
don't work yeah most of them don't work
a lot of them probably didn't but they
and then people were encouraging the
women to take the day off work and then
on on twitter
there's this i don't know if you've ever
heard of a group called rubber bandits
no yeah
so they're like uh kind of because it
sounds like a home loan three they're
kind of a comedy thing but
i saw them uh tweet that men should go
out and support the women
for repeal the whatever the strike for
appeal and
take the day off work as well and i said
they sound hilarious by the way for a
comedy
all right and then i said that's well
and good for you to say i was like but
you know
i was like i said you should change your
name to the white knights
and i was like you know you're like they
got mad like the media like i was like
you know
i was like i wouldn't go to tell me to
take the day off work you know you don't
have to work hard like
i'm sure i got criticized for that as
well but well you know that's what
happens when it's twitter twitter's not
real life hey
speaking of comedy we appreciate taking
the time to i think we have to get the
scotsman in here because uh he's had
he's had a few
all right hey come on mister come on
scotsman you got to get in here right we
need us
oh come on now you were just you were
just you were just shadow boxing in the
corner there
he was shadow boxing is getting ready it
was like her that scene with hurricane
denzel washington in the prison
all right there we go all right rep you
represent oh come on now come on move
move on over you get a little let's get
a little closer let's see let's see now
they can see you on camera now what's
what's your name
all in i just know you're scotsman uh
you're gonna have to hit me one more
time
huh kevin kevin kevin
dockery dockery
yeah okay i got it okay you're looking
at me like i got it wrong no i got it
right okay
so kevin uh what do you do first off
what are you doing in ireland
uh okay hey what's up
as far as like you know americans we
think of scotland and ireland as pretty
similar
what's the big difference like is it a
lot more mountainous
in scotland no
they love these bro they're very similar
little obvious no no i'm saying is it is
it is it like more mountainous as a
region in scotland
it's more hilly in ireland this is
called breaking the ice
skull is bailey okay all right so what's
the impression that you have the scots
have of americans
she's still laughing at my fat ass she
can't get over it in the potato
americans because
donald trump's a man so you think you
okay so there we go okay listen no you
you can't walk away now you have to stay
here we have to stay here huh
stay in the pocket so he said donald
trump's a man long as he keeps his
story loves keeps the story so you
probably can't
really even agree with him on everything
but you like what is it you like about
him that you say he's a man
it's right he's honestly right he's
he's scottish is he scottish yes he's
half scottish
okay do you think that's what makes him
so bold uh yes
yeah do you think it's a part of it um
so when you were watching the election
then
were you rooting for them i i had them
at 12 to 1.
you really did another third one i've
been six grand i put 500 pounds
did you did you actually bet on donald
trump yep wow
i made sex thousand pound awful oh my
gosh
nate's nate silver you lost to a
scotsman who had one too many
nate silver the brilliant men who who's
ready to come out
oh daryl okay well i said that big
section
by the way i thought i thought he made
six grand on donald trump winning all
right now he's gotta go
all right listen i don't know i think we
said this is this is just this is the
nature of
the show from a pub this is the show all
right let's bring him on here i didn't
mention the name of the pub because i
didn't know
did you oh did i i don't know but that
was targeted small that was so that's
only a small amount of people
so we can say you want to say all right
he's been very very nice here lucas barr
and am i pronouncing annis okay were you
worried at all when you heard we were
coming over to do this
no i think i i think i actually answered
the uh the the request before i even
looked you guys up
okay well then your mistake yeah no no
it wasn't too late
well you've been really accommodating
here um now what is
what would you say your perceptions are
i mean working in a bar working in a pub
most people in ireland their uh
perceptions of americans right now
right now in this climate right now i
mean i don't think it's that easy to do
define it don't think you can put your
finger on it as one particular brand
yeah it's layered because lots of people
have
their own personal connections with the
us actual family connections and
cultural connections yeah so it's not
that easy to
to put your finger on it obviously we
get a lot of our our information from
the european media from the irish media
and a little bit of the us media so that
that tempers it but
i mean ireland has always been generally
positively disposed towards the us just
because
it is like an extended family for us so
it'll never be entirely negative
i think it's more i think people feel a
little bit of ownership of the us you
know people here
feel as though when something they don't
like is happening uh they feel kind of
uh
disenfranchised they've contributed a
lot to the american culture we certainly
believe so yeah
yeah i mean you have you know the irish
the italians or some of the first waves
of immigrants who came in and became
americans
are actually some of the proudest
americans you know to be there in that
country
um well let me ask you one thing that we
noticed we even talked with people here
even though we talk about the eu brexit
probably won't happen with ireland there
seems to be a strong streak of
you know national pride people some
people call it nationalism in ireland
but national pride pride in your country
we were just talking we were in a
breakfast place by the way things opened
really late here in case you didn't know
compared to the states it was a cup we
could find a coffee place open before
nine so
is it just the breakfast locations
aren't particularly ambitious who wants
coffee before night
you don't have a coffee machine well we
would not when we travel here but we're
sitting there like no no one wants to
work that early
um so we were surprised as a lady she
said i said how do you what do you think
about americans
she said well you know we like americans
all right we [ __ ]
hate the english well we hate the accent
we haven't put the accent on i know
yeah well that is that's like we can we
can say that
um in many ways that's our word that's
our term we we can say that all we want
because of what was done to us but it's
meant
as a kind rebuff it's like uh they're
our friends who were super bad to us in
the past yeah everyone heard that is
dead
and everyone that did it too was dead
but that was your greeting to americans
yeah that was your greeting to america
that was your favorite that was our
first
impression she always got another coffee
yet
could you imagine though if you came
over to the stage and said hey what do
you think about the irish
ah you guys are okay we hate mexicans
yeah i mean that would not go over well
that's one that is one issue i think
america that a lot of people um we don't
understand is is
if americans have pride in their country
national pride often abroad it's seen as
uh being highly valued as pompous it's
seen as
racist but by extension you'll find that
you you find it very difficult to find
uh if you go to britain
you'll find lots of proud uh scots lots
of proud
welsh yeah you find it very difficult to
find a very proud and
an outwardly proud english person
because it is associated with
triumphalism
so there could be a touch of that i mean
it could be that you guys
uh see yourselves as being triumphalist
if if you're running someone else down
the english i know that they do that i
know that they feel that way it's
actually unfortunate
they can't they can't to a full extent
celebrate their own culture do you think
that because of that sort of brow
beating and that guilt that they feel
maybe that's where
i mean if you look at the younger
generation a surprising amount of them
were pro brexit
a surprising amount of young people yeah
i mean surprise
you know it's always you're taking these
things relatively right for example when
we say generation z
is a generation below millennials the
most conservative generation ever
what that means is if you look at baby
boomers who are now conservative
yes uh uh actually yeah my dad ended up
like 16 you know when they were young
they were the flower child hippies so
they became yeah and they became more
conservative
but now even at a young age
comparatively they're
much more right-leaning and i'm
wondering if it's because maybe they're
separated from that that guilt maybe a
lot of young english people say you know
what
i didn't do anything wrong and uh i like
my country i'm proud of my country i
i can't speak with that i don't know i
will always have the impression that the
opposite of the case is actually younger
people in the uk certainly
who are a little bit uh more aware of
the evils done but i mean they tried to
take over the world
right and they they tried very hard and
they came down close to you kind of lost
your number one draft
pick with uh the united states england
so sorry that got away from you
we did pretty well well we're doing okay
too yeah ireland did pretty well too
yeah uh
but yeah so so i think that my
impression is that younger people in the
uk would have more
more awareness of of what it used to be
for the british empire brexit seems to
be
um almost like a grasp but at the olden
days or the
the days never even existed before the
golden years of their imagination people
kind of
think they had this great empire where
everyone liked them and they got along
with everyone and they were all very
racist but they weren't rich people were
rich yeah poor people report
well i mean how much of it is is uh you
know uh imperialist versus people who
just you know don't want to be like you
said we were talking about germany with
the eu don't want to be putting the bill
for other people and again don't want to
be guilted and don't want to have their
own policies and laws dictated to them
you know i think you see what donald
trump is a symptom
you know when people talk about that
people are made ashamed to be american
people are made ashamed to be
male you know for a long time now you
have campuses we're saying check your
privilege check your white privilege
your mail privilege and they actually
have courses to uh
deconstruct and deprogram being a male
in college these are actual
these are actual courses now and i think
that maybe the political spectrum
they've reached so
far right now on the left that's where
you're seeing a lot of people like this
a rejection
like i said if you have 30 of young
people who are leaning right it doesn't
sound like a lot but compared to
previous generations where it might have
been
15 that's a shocking amount
um typically you know anyone before the
age of 30 tended to be very very left
and we're not seeing that anymore
and we're just sort of as people who
study sociologists people who study kind
of human condition with the show
obviously with comedy it's something
that everyone has a different answer for
um and it's surprising to hear different
points of view in europe
yeah i'm sure they had a lot of stats
i mean there's a comparison i don't have
the exact number on them but generation
they call them z
are becoming more and more right-leaning
and a lot of them not right leaning
necessarily politically but culturally
as freedom of speech it could seem to be
it could be simply a symptom of uh
generations getting more right wing and
then
moving on to the next generation it
could be a cycle i don't know that yeah
it could be
yeah well you people final thing you
said people here don't really care about
the political correctness like they like
they like comedy just be comedy so
that's something has that always been
the case or do you think again that's a
rejection because in the states you know
it's gotten to a point where you can't
say anything you have people being fired
for tweets that offend folks
well there is there is the fact that we
are in the early years of a lot of
social media too so it's very different
uh
i mean it happens here as well people
don't know what to do with it uh where
do you buy an iphone around here by the
way we were
we're buying an iphone around here in a
telephone shop we didn't see any
we walked we've been walking around we
haven't seen anything there's entire
streets in this town that do nothing but
cell phones oh really okay well
okay all right let's see
no we didn't see anything you know
you'll go through these villages and
you'll see an obviously it's beautiful
there's
there's a lot more history here than the
united states but we didn't see anything
like a cell phone shop so
you have to go to the cell phone street
in this town certainly
in this town there's a street yeah
they're out there it's like your jewelry
district this is where you want to buy
your phones
and who are your carriers it's not
sprint please tell me don't have sprint
uh no i'm not i'm not sure what you guys
call vodafone
verizon possibly i'm not sure verizon
very nice we've got vodafone we've got a
couple of uh
a couple of native ones i've gotta go to
i think i'm actually there's a bunch of
those
listen we know you have to go back to
work on the bar there but hey dare thank
you so much for taking time we
appreciate it it's been a
very illuminating experience is this
dean coming in here oh black donnelly it
looks like the black donald is kid
so no we're gonna we'll just keep this
yeah we'll probably wrap it we will
wanna okay dean we have to wrap you
really quickly
dean will be last night you can bring
him in bring him in bring him ring bring
him in this is what happened this is
what happens when you're broadcasting
and there's alcohol involved people just
come on in and uh
do you want to take shots at my father
am i fat ass yeah no thanks you sure
yeah yeah no positive that's kind of a
theme going on tonight so
what that's massive all right freedom of
speech in ireland what do you think do
you think do you think that's under
assault uh
to a point i don't agree with the
blasphemy no
no no not at all but uh yeah it's very
um it's very uh
some things are kind of untouchable i
can't really talk about islam
ridiculed in some sort away or same with
abortion same with anything you're
kind of branded okay
we kind of we're going to wrap this up
so let me ask this do you see that
getting better or do you see people kind
of waking up now do you see
because because the truth is we talk
about this western civilization in
europe
and political islam are incompatible
that's just reality do you think
people are going to wake up to it as
you're seeing that now with ireland or
do you want or do you think it just
first until europe just kind of
collapses on itself
i think they have to happen you know i
think they do i don't know if you know
but i mean the most
popular name baby name in ireland at the
moment is muhammad
really yeah yeah that was the statistic
only came out there about a week ago
you wonder how much of it is like
self-perpetuating though it's because
they sell so many of the muhammad bumper
stickers
people like well i know that if i name
my kid muhammad i'll always have an axe
i always have it at the joker
find the keychain yes liberal people
never do it just for the sake
yeah just for the sake of it yeah yeah
now do you think is your sense do you
think there's a general sentiment that
people
are concerned or are most people trying
to turn a blind eye in my immediate
circle
yes certain extent like but um
i can't handle the online stuff i get
too heated right you get to eat it
yeah i do yeah well we don't want that
to happen because you're irish when you
guys get heated
which is funny because you should be
able to handle your liquor but you fight
a lot when you drink
uh i don't know to be honest maybe maybe
a bit when i was younger but not anymore
i'm very settled no i have three or four
points on that'll be about it but
if you catch me in a saturday night
it'll be a different story
yes you well that's more so him playing
possum oh i hope no one tries to take
advantage
and he lays back down but i'm just a
simple little potato
i'm just a simple potato uh okay well
listen
thank you so much for for taking the
time and um it is you know
we'll wrap us up here we're here lucas
bar and anna ireland they've been
incredibly welcoming incredibly kind
i still don't know that we have a ton of
answers i'm kind of surprised by
people answering on individual questions
lining up more right
you seem to see but then thinking
overall no we're more left
and i think that might be the issue with
europe i think there might be some
cognitive dis
i think they may have had a point right
now
this one said how to punt yeah i had a
point i had four points so you know in
ireland that's called moderate drinking
um so you can tweet us at s crowd or at
knock aj and let us know what you think
um
what's the direction of europe you know
a lot of people get really defensive
they get mad listen i don't get mad when
we say that united states has issues
that we have problems um
i want to get proactive and fix them
seems like a lot of people in ireland at
least are looking to do that
it seems like some people in europe and
it seems like some other folks i think
we're catching them in the thought
process the transition transition yeah
and so it's kind of a
just it's the beginning of the awakening
it's the unique
yes it's the fulfilling of the awakening
you know that's what it
is yeah well who knows we'll see what
happens and uh
we'll see if in five years from now
muhammad is the most common name in
ireland
that is scary think about that that's
scary you know muhammad
is the number one name in ireland
imagine that in scotland that would
change
all of braveheart maybe moms are just
kind of lazy kind of like uh
what's this face uh george foreman yeah
just just have eight kids and name them
all muhammad
i don't that's it listen a lot of
crowder live from ireland
we never know we do these shows on
locations but uh we'll see uh where we
end up next and we're gonna go to the
santorum wedding tomorrow that should be
fun should be
should be beautiful beautiful in ireland
so they have that going for them
regardless of what else happens
see you next week